This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Last week on the show, we featured the story of Randy Gardner, a San Diego man who went 11 days without sleeping, breaking a world record. You don't need sleep. That was the thinking back in the 60s and that's the thinking that I had. Of course, as it turns out, that was absolutely wrong. Randy's exploit would come back to hunt him later on in life in the form of crippling insomnia.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在上周的节目中，我们讲述了兰迪·加德纳的故事，他是圣迭戈的一名男子，在不睡觉的情况下坚持了11天，打破了世界纪录。你不需要睡觉。这就是60年代的想法，也是我当时的看法。当然，事实证明，那是完全错误的。兰迪当年的壮举后来卷土重来，以严重的失眠症的形式在晚年折磨了他。
This week on the show, we continue to look at sleep and explore one of the greatest mysteries in human behavior. Nature has endowed us with an amazing brain. So why in the world would nature have that very same brain put itself to sleep for one third of our lives. If we didn't need eight hours of sleep and we could survive on six, mother nature would have done away with 25% of our sleep time millions of years ago. Because when you think about it, sleep is an idiotic thing to do. If sleep does not provide a remarkable set of benefits, then
在本周的节目中，我们将继续关注睡眠，并探索人类行为中最大的谜团之一。大自然赋予了我们一颗神奇的大脑。那么，大自然为什么偏偏要让这颗神奇的大脑在我们生命的三分之一时间里进入睡眠状态呢？如果我们不需要八个小时的睡眠，靠六个小时就能存活，那么数百万年前大自然母亲就会把我们25%的睡眠时间取消了。因为仔细想想，睡觉是一件极其愚蠢的事。如果睡眠不能带来一系列惊人的好处，那么
it's the biggest mistake the evolutionary process has ever made. Matthew Walker is a professor of neuroscience and psychology at the University of California at Berkeley. He studies sleep and he's the author of the book, Why We Sleep? I started our conversation by asking him to tell me a story he describes in his book. It's about a pianist who relied on sleep for his creative process. Yeah, I was giving a public lecture on sleep and at the time we didn't know too much about sleep's role in learning and memory of which we now know a great deal. And this wonderful sort of distinguished looking gentleman with a fantastic kindly face walked to me, stressed in this
这就是进化史上犯下的最大错误。马修·沃克是加利福尼亚大学伯克利分校的神经科学和心理学教授。他专门研究睡眠，也是《为什么要睡觉？》一书的作者。我与他对话的开始，是请他讲一个他在书中描述的故事。那是关于一位在创作过程中依赖睡眠的钢琴家。是的，当时我正在做一个关于睡眠的公众演讲，而那时我们对睡眠在学习和记忆中所起的作用知之甚少，而我们现在对这些已经有了很深的了解。一个身材匀称、长相斯文、面容慈祥的绅士向我走来，他穿着一身
great sort of tweed suit. And he said, I'm a pianist and I was fascinated by what you were saying about sleep and how active a brain state it is. And I wanted to tell you that there are times when I will be trying to learn a new piece and I just can't get it. And I get frustrated, I make the same mistake at the same place each and every time. And I'll sometimes play late into the evening and I will walk away continuing to be frustrated. Have a night of sleep. And then when I come back and I sit down the next morning, I can just play perfectly. Perfectly.
很棒的粗花呢西装。他对我说：“我是一名钢琴家，你刚才讲的关于睡眠以及它是一种多么活跃的大脑状态的内容，让我非常着迷。我想告诉你的是，有时我在学一首新曲子时就是学不会。我感到很沮丧，每次都在同一个地方犯同样的错误。有时我会弹到深夜，然后带着沮丧的心情离开。睡上一觉。第二天早上我回来坐下时，就能弹得完美无缺。完美无缺。”
And what he was suggesting perhaps was that it wasn't practice that made perfect. It was practice with a night of sleep that made perfect. I want to run two other examples by you, both of which seem to suggest that remarkable things happen to us while we're sleeping. I understand the guitarist Keith Richards from Rolling Stones kept his instrument and a recorder by his bed, and he did it in case inspiration struck while he was asleep. Did it ever happen? It did, and I think it's one of the wonderful stories of sleep-inspired creativity of which there are many.
而他暗示的或许并不是熟能生巧。而是练习加上一晚上的睡眠才成就了完美。我想跟你探讨另外两个例子，这两个例子似乎都表明，我们在睡觉时会发生非同寻常的事情。据我所知，滚石乐队的吉他手基思·里查兹在床边放了一把乐器和一个录音机，他这样做是为了防止自己在睡着时灵感突发。这真的发生过吗？确实发生过，我认为这是众多受睡眠启发的创造力故事中最精彩的一个。
He would have this tape recorder and he would have his guitar and you know it was a hotel, surrounded in the bedroom at the time. And one morning he woke up and the tape had recorded all the way to the end. And he didn't remember anything about that night. So he rewound the tape and he played it and he says, and this is in his autobiography, there was almost this sort of ghostly vision of him strumming the chords to satisfaction. Arguably, the most popular Rolling Stone song ever and he said he created that classic
他会有这个录音机，还会有他的吉他，你知道那是一个酒店，当时卧室里到处都是。一天早上他醒来时，磁带已经录到了尽头。他对那天晚上的事一点印象也没有。于是他倒回磁带并播放了它，他在自传中写道，当时几乎有一种幽灵般的幻象，看到自己在弹奏《Satisfaction》的和弦。可以说是滚石乐队有史以来最受欢迎的歌曲，他说他创造了那个经典的
guitar riff from his sleep. It was a dream inspired musical piece of creativity followed by about 42 minutes of snoring. Lots of scientific discoveries, though, to have been birthed by way of dream-sleep inspired creativity. Speaking of scientific discoveries, I understand there's a connection between sleep and the discovery of the periodic table. Dimitri Mendelayev was trying to understand how all of the known elements in the universe fit together, and it was his obsession for years, and he struggled, and he couldn't figure out, he would create playing cards with all of the different elements and he would deal them to see if he could find some equation by way of which they all fit
吉他副歌来自他的睡眠。这是一首受梦境启发的音乐创意作品，随后大约有42分钟的鼾声。不过，许多科学发现似乎也是通过受梦睡眠启发的创造力而诞生的。说到科学发现，据我所知，睡眠和元素周期表的发现之间存在某种联系。德米特里·门捷列夫曾试图理解宇宙中所有已知的元素是如何组合在一起的，这是他多年的痴迷，他苦苦思索却百思不得其解，他制作了印有所有不同元素的扑克牌，然后把它们发出去，看能否找到某种方程让它们全部契合
together. And apparently Sir The Stry goes February 17th 1869, he fell asleep exhausted, frustrated, couldn't figure it out. And that in his sleeping brain emerged the solution that his waking brain could not divine. He started to realize how all of these swirling elemental ingredients could actually snap together in this sort of what he described as a divine grid where where you had each row, each period, and each column, each group having this logical progression of atomic and orbiting electron characteristics. And he woke up and he pinned down
在一起。显然，历史记载是1869年2月17日，他精疲力竭、倍感沮丧地睡着了，还是没能解开谜题。正是在他睡眠的大脑中，浮现出了他清醒的大脑无法破解的解决方案。他开始意识到所有这些盘旋的元素成分如何在一种他所描述的神奇网格中完美契合，在这里，每一行、每一个周期、每一个列、每一个组都具有这种合乎逻辑的原子和轨道电子特性的渐变规律。他醒来后便记下了
this remarkable table, the table that we now call the periodic table of elements. And he noted that he made just perhaps one or two changes. And that documents that exist, you can still see that dream-inspired piece of creativity. So, yeah, there is one of the greatest, I think, arguable problems to solve. And it wasn't a waking brain that solved it. It was a sleeping and a dreaming brain that did it. Matthew says there are two types of sleep. Rapid eye movement sleep, also known as REM. This is when we dream.
这张非凡的表格，也就是我们今天所说的元素周期表。他指出自己仅仅做了一处或两处的修改。现存的文献证明，你依然可以看到那个受梦境启发的创意杰作。所以，是的，这是我认为最伟大的、可以说是亟待解决的问题之一。解决它的不是清醒的大脑，而是睡眠和做梦的大脑。马修说，睡眠有两种类型。快速眼动睡眠，也称为REM。这就是我们做梦的时候。
Then there's non-rappad eye movement sleep or non-rem. And those two types of sleep actually play out in this wonderful battle for brain domination throughout the night. And that cerebral war is one and lost every 90 minutes and then replayed every 90 minutes to produce what we call a sleep cycle. And you go down into non-rem sleep first and then you go up into REM sleep and then you repeat the cycle. You say that non-rem sleep might be implicated or involved in cementing memories, and that there's a popular song that might get it this idea. Because a vision softly creeping Left it seeds while I was sleeping And both vision that was planted in my brain
然后是非快速眼动睡眠，或称非REM。这两种类型的睡眠实际上在整夜中上演着争夺大脑主导地位的奇妙战役。这种大脑之战每90分钟就会分出一次胜负，然后每90分钟重演一次，从而产生我们所说的睡眠周期。你会先进入非REM睡眠，然后上升到REM睡眠，接着重复这个循环。你说非REM睡眠可能与巩固记忆有关或参与其中，并且有一首流行歌曲可能捕捉到了这个概念。因为一个轻柔蔓延的幻象在我睡着时留下了它的种子在我脑海中种下的那个幻象
Still remains So Matthew, what does Simon and Garfunkel get right about Narn Ram sleep? It is prophetic wisdom of the most remarkable kind. You know, I think that they were suggesting things that were 20, 30 years ahead of their time. We now know that we imprint information during the day. We sort of that seed is planted there within the brain during the day, in other words we learn information. But we also know that that vision that was planted in the brain
依然存在 那么马修，西蒙与加芬克尔乐队对非REM睡眠的理解到底对在哪里？这是最非凡的一种先知般的智慧。你知道，我认为他们提出的观点比他们的时代超前了20、30年。我们现在知道，我们在白天时会印刻信息。也就是说，那种种子在白天时就被种植在了大脑内部，换句话说，我们学习了信息。但我们也知道，那个种植在大脑中的幻象
still remains in the sound of silence, in this, in the dark of night, and it's there that specifically deep non-rem sleep goes to perform its memory functions. Deep non-rem sleep almost hits the save button on those recently acquired informational pieces so that when you wake up the next morning, you have remembering rather than forgetting. Non-rem is all about helping us retain information. And as we saw from the music of the Rolling Stones and the creation of the periodic table, REM sleep, Dream sleep, spurs creativity. But Matthew says, Dream's also have another function. The second function, however, is very different. That function seems to be about emotional therapy or what I would describe as overnight therapy. Dream sleep provides a fascinating neurochemical soothing balm. It is during dream sleep and only
依然存在于寂静之声中，在这黑夜之中，正是正宗的深层非REM睡眠在执行它的记忆功能。深层非REM睡眠几乎为你最近获得的那些信息片段按下了保存键，这样当你第二天早上醒来时，你拥有的是回忆而不是遗忘。非REM的核心全在于帮助我们保留信息。正如我们从滚石乐队的音乐和元素周期表的创造中所看到的，REM睡眠、做梦睡眠会激发创造力。但马修说，梦还有另一个功能。然而，第二个功能却非常不同。那个功能似乎关乎情感疗愈，或者我所描述的过夜疗愈。梦境睡眠提供了一种迷人的神经化学舒缓膏。正是在梦境睡眠期间，且仅在
during dream sleep when our brain shuts off a stress-related neurochemical called noradrenaline. Now it's cystic chemical, everyone will be familiar with in the body, that's called adrenaline, but the version of it upstairs in the brain is called noradrenaline, and it's during dream sleep that that chemical is actually shut off. But what we also know is that the emotional and memory centers of the brain during dream sleep light up in terms of their activity. And so we've proposed that DreamSleep provides this perfect opportunity where we can start to reactivate and replay painful, difficult emotional experiences.
梦境睡眠期间，我们的大脑才会关闭一种与压力相关的神经化学物质，叫做去甲肾上腺素。现在这种化学物质，每个人在身体里都会很熟悉，叫做肾上腺素，但它在大脑上层的版本被称为去甲肾上腺素，正是在梦境睡眠期间，这种化学物质实际上被关闭了。但我们也知道，在梦境睡眠期间，大脑的情感和记忆中心在活动方面会被点亮。因此我们提出，梦境睡眠提供了一个绝佳的机会，让我们能够开始重新激活和重演那些痛苦、困难的情感经历。
But we do so in a neurochemically quote unquote, safe environment. And we now understand that dream sleep actually helps separate and strip away that painful emotional sting from those informational experiences so that you wake up feeling better about it. You wake up with a memory of an emotional event, but is no longer emotional itself. It's that form of nocturnal therapy. But what about bad dreams? Hi, I'm Greta Pittenger. Greta is a researcher at NPR,
但我们是在一个神经化学意义上的所谓“安全环境”中这样做的。我们现在了解到，梦境睡眠实际上有助于将那种痛苦的情感刺痛感从那些信息经验中分离并剥离出去，这样你醒来时会感觉好一些。你醒来时带着对某个情感事件的记忆，但它本身不再具有情感色彩。这就是那种夜间疗愈的形式。但是噩梦呢？嗨，我是格雷塔·皮廷格。格雷塔是NPR的一名研究员，
and about eight or nine years ago, her relationship with sleep changed. I let her tell you the story. I had been dating a guy who is now my husband, but at the time we were just dating. He wrote a motorcycle and that was his only form of transportation. So whenever I'd go out with him or he'd drive me to work or something, I would ride on the back and had my own helmet and stuff. Late one night we were coming home from a party and we're in downtown Seattle Streets were pretty empty, but we were going pretty slow coming out of a stoplight and
大约八九年前，她与睡眠的关系发生了改变。我让她来给你讲讲这个故事。我当时在和一个现在已经成了我丈夫的男生交往，但当时我们只是在约会。他骑摩托车，那是他唯一的交通工具。所以每当我跟他出去，或者他开车送我去上班之类的时候，我都会坐在后座上，戴着我自己的头盔之类的东西。有一天深夜，我们从一个派对回来，正行驶在西雅图市中心的街道上。街道上空无一人，但我们在绿灯过后车速很慢，
a large white SUV Ranna red light and crashed into us from the left side The next thing I remember is waking up on my back in like a elevated planter kind of off on the side of the sidewalk. You know, there's like the street on one side and then the other side has like a little kind of retaining wall with like plants and ferns. And so I was kind of halfway into that.
一辆大型白色SUV闯了红灯，从左侧撞上了我们。我记得的下一件事就是仰面躺在路边一个类似加高的花坛里。你知道的，一边是街道，另一边则是一个带有植物和蕨类植物的小型挡土墙。所以我差不多有一半身体陷在里面。
It was about I had flown off the bike and hit my right thigh on that concrete planter and broke the femur right and half. And when I woke up I was on my back with my legs kind of dangling and there was flames around me. And then that's when I think I saw my then boyfriend Joey on the sidewalk and it was like he was also injured separately but didn't have much time to think about any of those things because luckily the police station was two blocks away and so then police were the first people there and then came and dragged us out. The actual crash of the car had punctured the motorcycle and then there were the
大概是我从车上飞了出去，右大腿撞到了那个混凝土花坛上，右大腿骨当场断成了两截。当我醒来时，我仰面躺着，双腿无力地垂着，四周都是火焰。然后我想我看到了当时的男朋友乔伊正躺在人行道上，他好像也受了伤，但没有太多时间去想这些事情，因为幸运的是，警察局就在两个街区外，所以警察是第一批到达现场的人，然后过来把我们拖了出来。汽车真正的撞击刺破了摩托车，然后
first sound I really remember was an explosion. Of the motorcycle tank blowing up which was, yeah, I don't trust my memories of how intense it was, but it was very, very scary. Joey actually broke the other femur. He broke his left femur from the impact of the car. I broke my right femur from hitting that wall. He also broke a few other bones. So I stayed in the hospital for maybe four days after surgery. And he stayed for, I want to say at least a full week, maybe 10 days, because you had a couple surgeries. I didn't sleep pretty much at all.
我真正能记起的第一声音效是一声爆炸。摩托车油箱爆炸了，这真是——是的，我不相信自己记忆中当时的情况有多么激烈，但它非常非常可怕。乔伊实际上断了另一根大腿骨。汽车撞击导致他的左大腿骨折了。我因为撞到那堵墙而右大腿骨折了。他还断了其他几根骨头。所以我手术后在医院住了大约四天。而他住了，我想说至少整整一周，也许10天，因为你做了好几次手术。我几乎根本无法入睡。
Partially because of the painkillers, but I think also that's when, like, bad dreams were starting, and I couldn't stop reliving that moment of the crash. I'm not sure if I had these exact dreams in the hospital, but for a couple of years after all of this, I would just keep having dreams about things crashing into me or things running over me. And then specifically that moment also when that car hit us. I would keep going back to that and I remember waking up with a start. You know, like when you wake up suddenly and sometimes you can't remember why, but you know you feel like you fell.
部分原因是止痛药的关系，但我觉得这也是噩梦开始的时候，我无法停止重温那场车祸的时刻。我不确定我在医院里是否做过这些确切的梦，但在这一切发生后的好几年里，我总是不断梦到有东西撞向我，或者有东西从我身上碾过。尤其是汽车撞击我们的那一刻。我会不断回到那个场景，并且我记得自己常常惊醒。你知道的，就像你突然醒来时有时想不起原因，但你知道自己感觉像是在下坠。
You feel like you just fell into bed, that feeling. I like to write, and I've kept a journal since I was in fourth grade. I had written about it right after it happened. At my mom's insistence, I was staying with her, my dad, at the time, and just like, I'd wake up from my nap just bawling. She her, my dad, at the time, and it's just like, I'd wake up from my nap just bawling.
你感觉自己刚刚坠入床铺，就是那种感觉。我喜欢写作，从四年级起我就开始写日记。事情发生后不久我就把它写了下来。在我妈妈的坚持下，当时我正和她以及我爸爸住在一起，就像这样，我从午睡中醒来时嚎啕大哭。她——当时她和爸爸都在，就像这样，我午睡醒来就一直在嚎啕大哭。
She said, you know, maybe you should just write it down and let it go. Kind of hoping that might help, and I think it did for a little bit, but then it kept coming back and I tried to avoid it. She's like, you need me. I'm the motorcycle tank. When we were talking about dreams some time ago, Matthew, you said that one of the potential virtues of dreams is that they might allow us to relive or experience things that happen to us or things that might happen to us in a relatively safe space. And as we do this, we process what happened and then potentially learn from it.
她说，你知道的，也许你应该把它写下来然后放下。有点希望能有所帮助，我想它确实起了一点作用，但后来它又回来了，我试图避开它。她说：“你需要我。我是那个摩托车油箱。”马修，不久前我们在谈论梦的时候，你曾说过，梦的潜在优点之一是它们可能允许我们在一个相对安全的空间里重温或经历发生在我们身上的事情，或者可能会发生在我们身上的事情。当我们这样做时，我们处理了发生的事情，然后可能从中吸取教训。
What about nightmares, though? Nightmares are not pleasant, they can be disruptive, they can actually be acutely painful, and certainly in Greta's case, they were disruptive to her life. Why would the brain be designed to have nightmares? It's not clear whether the brain actually is designed to have nightmares or whether this is actually the process going awry. And we think it may be the latter because when we look at patients, for example, who have post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD, repetitive nightmares are actually so reliable in those patients that they actually form part of the diagnostic criteria for
那么噩梦呢？噩梦并不愉快，它们具有破坏性，实际上可能会带来剧烈的痛苦，对格雷塔的情况来说，它们确实对她的生活造成了干扰。为什么大脑会被设计成会做噩梦呢？目前还不清楚大脑是否真的被设计成会做噩梦，或者这实际上是运作出了差错的过程。我们认为可能是后者，因为当我们观察患有创伤后应激障碍（简称PTSD）的患者时，重复性的噩梦在这些患者中是如此稳定，以至于它们实际上构成了该疾病本身诊断标准的一部分。
that disorder itself. So there is something strange that we've yet to fully understand about particularly emotionally intense trauma dreams. What we think is happening in the case of PTSD is that that chemical that we spoke about that normally is shut off during dream sleep, the chemical noradrenaline remains too high. And it may be that when that chemical is too high in its concentration, we can't gift ourselves that normal therapeutic benefit that REM sleep provides, so that the dreams themselves become particularly emotionally strong and difficult and you don't get that resolution the next day.
因此，关于那些特别是情感强度极高的创伤梦，有一些奇怪之处是我们尚未完全理解的。我们认为在PTSD的情况下发生的情况是，我们之前谈到的那种通常在梦境睡眠期间会关闭的化学物质——去甲肾上腺素的水平依然过高。而且当这种化学物质浓度过高时，我们可能无法获得REM睡眠所提供的正常治疗效益，以至于梦境本身变得特别具有情感冲击力并且难以应对，你第二天也无法获得那种心理上的释怀。
And so the process steps and repeats and it happens time and time again. And it is perhaps only when there is some degree of contextualization, be it by way of medication that is now given to certain PTSD, war veterans, for example, drugs out there that seem to help lower that chemical, that stress-related chemical, give them normal dream sleep and it gives them back that ability to process those events. That's one way to help. Another is that perhaps by journaling it and going through that process of shifting the context or reformulating it in one's mind, it becomes less stressful. In fact, this is exactly what Greta discovered herself to.
于是这个过程不断重复，一次又一次地发生。也许只有当某种程度的语境化出现时——比如通过现在给某些PTSD患者（例如战争退伍军人）使用的药物，那些似乎有助于降低这种化学物质、这种与压力相关的化学物质的药物，赋予他们正常的梦境睡眠，才能让他们恢复处理这些事件的能力。这是一种辅助方法。另一种方法或许是通过写日记，经历转变语境或在脑海中重新构思这一过程，让它变得没有那么大压力。事实上，这正是格雷塔自己发现的方法。
So about two or three years after the crash, I was finally seeing a psychiatrist about the kind of lasting trauma and trying to get over that and try to, trying to sleep. I mean, I was trying to help my insomnia as well. And we talked about those dreams and he suggested, he knew I like to write and so he suggested in my journal just rewriting that dream because it's a dream, it's not reality and so it doesn't need to mimic reality. So just change it. The way I changed that dream was that instead of a car coming and hitting the motorcycle, the motorcycle transformed into a winged horse and flew away. Away from the car, away from all that crash and then just landed safely back at our apartment, dropped us off.
所以在车祸发生大约两三年后，我终于去看了一位精神科医生，讨论持续的创伤，并试图克服它，尝试去睡觉。我的意思是，我也在试图治疗我的失眠。我们谈到了那些梦，他建议——他知道我喜欢写作——所以他建议在我的日记里重写那个梦，因为那是梦，不是现实，所以它不需要模仿现实。那就直接改变它吧。我改变那个梦的方式是，不再是一辆汽车开过来撞上摩托车，而是那辆摩托车变成了一匹带翅膀的马飞走了。
And so, writing about it again years later, but in a totally different way, not trying to be accurate, not trying to remember was much different. It definitely got me to stop having those vivid dreams. not trying to remember was much different. It definitely got me to stop having those vivid dreams. I've had flying dreams in the past, but I started to have more types of those dreams of kind of being lifted away from gravity and from the weight of these emotions. You know, like when you wake up from a dream and it doesn't really leave a mark on you, that was a good feeling to him, like, oh yeah, I guess I did have that dream.
远离汽车，远离所有的撞击，然后安全地降落在我们的公寓，把我们放了下来。因此，在多年后再次写下它，但用一种完全不同的方式，不试图去追求准确，不试图去回忆，感觉大不相同了。它确实让我不再做那些生动的噩梦了。不试图去回忆，感觉大不相同了。它确实让我不再做那些生动的噩梦了。我过去也做过会飞的梦，但我开始做更多那种摆脱了重力、摆脱了这些情感负担的被托举起来的梦。你知道，就像你从一个梦中醒来，它并没有真正在你身上留下痕迹，那是一种很好的感觉，就觉得“哦，对啊，我好像确实做了那个梦”。
Oh yeah, that was nice. Just like this past month, Joey and I bought Moe Peds, which is like something he used to do before he even had a motorcycle, and I have never ridden before, and I'm like, I feel like such a badass on this, like little like, ah, like it's such a dorky little like, rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr When we come back, we look at the amazing range of things a good night's sleep can accomplish. You know, sleep is the swissahome knife of health. So let's talk just for a bit about the amount of sleep that people need.
“哦，对啊，那感觉真好。”就在上个月，我和乔伊买了轻便摩托车，这有点像他甚至在有摩托车之前就经常做的事，而我以前从来没骑过，我就觉得，骑着这个小东西，我简直酷毙了——啊，就像一个书呆子气的小东西，突突突突突突……当我们回来时，我们将探讨一觉好眠能够达成的惊人成就。你知道，睡眠是健康的瑞士军刀。所以我们来简单谈谈人们需要的睡眠量。
You and many other experts say people should strive to get 8 hours of sleep every night. To tell you the truth, I got about 6 hours last night and I feel fine. Tell me where you live, I'm coming around tonight, we will have a sleep salon, a sleep salon, I will inflict change no matter what. Here's my question Matthew, if I can get away with sleeping 25% less than the recommended amount one night, why can't I do it every night? And just think of the upside, you know, I can spend two hours every day reading wonderful books like yours, building a better podcast, being more productive, surely it's a good thing.
你和许多其他专家都表示，人们应该争取每晚睡8个小时。说实话，我昨晚只睡了大约6个小时，我感觉很好。告诉我你住哪儿，我今晚就过去，我们要开个睡眠沙龙，一个睡眠沙龙，无论如何我都得带来改变。我的问题是，马修，如果我有一天可以比推荐量少睡25%而安然无恙，为什么我不能每天都这样？想想看，好处多大啊，我每天可以花两个小时阅读像你写的这样美妙的书，打造更好的播客，变得更有生产力，这绝对是件好事。
If we didn't need eight hours of sleep and we could survive on six, mother nature would have done away with 25% of our sleep time millions of years ago. Because when you think about it, sleep is an idiotic thing to do. You're not finding a mate, you're not reproducing, you're not finding food, you're not caring for your young, we're still you're vulnerable. So on any one of those counts, it should have been excised from the evolutionary process. So as it has been said before, if sleep does not provide a remarkable set of benefits, then it's the biggest mistake the evolutionary process has ever made. And it didn't make a spectacular blunder in putting in place
如果我们不需要八个小时的睡眠，靠六个小时就能存活，数百万年前大自然母亲就会把我们25%的睡眠时间取消了。因为仔细想想，睡眠是一件极其愚蠢的事。你找不到伴侣，你不进行繁殖，你找不到食物，你不照顾幼崽，最糟糕的是你还很脆弱。因此，凭这其中的任何一条，它本都应该在进化过程中被剔除。正如之前所说的那样，如果睡眠不能带来一系列惊人的好处，那么它就是进化史上犯下的最大错误。而且在经历了
through 3.6 million years of evolution this thing called an 8 hour sleep need. So I know that you think you're okay with 6 hours of sleep but trust me or not and we know this to be true that your subjective sense of how well you're doing on insufficient sleep is a miserable predictor of objectively how you're doing with too little sleep. So it's a little bit like a drunk driver at a bar, picks up their keys after, you know, six or seven shots and says, I'm fine to drive, off I go, and your response is no, I know that you think you're fine to drive subjectively, but objectively trust me, you're not, you're impaired. It's the same case with insufficient sleep, too. And I think it's one of the reasons that we often underestimate how damaging a lack of
360万年的进化过程中，它并没有在建立被称为8小时睡眠需求这件事上犯下惊人的大错。所以我知道你觉得自己睡6个小时没问题，但无论你信不信——我们知道这是事实——你对于自己在睡眠不足的情况下表现得有多好的主观感觉，是一个极其糟糕的预测指标，无法客观反映你因为睡眠过少而实际表现得如何。所以这有点像一个在酒吧里的醉酒司机，喝了六七杯酒后拿起钥匙说：“我开车没问题，我走了。”而你的反应是：“不，我知道你主观上觉得自己开车没问题，但客观地相信我，你不行，你受损了。”睡眠不足也是同样的道理。并且我认为这也是我们经常低估缺乏睡眠对我们的健康、保健和认知功能造成多么大破坏的原因之一。
sleep is on our health and our wellness and our cognitive function. I remember once going to a talk that showed the level of light pollution on the planet, the parts of the planet where they were the highest levels of artificial light. And then the researcher took that, you know, the image off the screen and replaced it with an image showing the distribution of prostate cancer around the world. And there was a remarkable correlation between the areas of the world which have light pollution, where presumably people are staying up later and later at night and presumably getting less sleep than they need, and the incidence of prostate cancer. Now of course this is a
我记得有一次去听一场讲座，讲座展示了地球上光污染的水平，也就是地球上人工光水平最高的部分。然后研究人员把那个（你知道的）屏幕上的图像拿掉，换成了一张显示全球前列腺癌分布的图像。全球光污染严重地区（人们晚上熬得越来越晚，睡眠可能达不到所需时间）与前列腺癌的发病率之间存在着惊人的相关性。当然，这只是一种
correlation we don't know if one is connected to the other but you said there has been some evidence at least that sleep might be implicated in the development of cancer. There is and it's fast becoming I think strong evidence and causal as well. We know, for example, that one single night of short sleep in these elaborate studies where you, perhaps, are limited to just four hours of sleep for one single night. The next day, that will draw critical anti-cancer fighting cells, called natural killer cells, by 70% to 70%. That is an alarming state of immune deficiency, and it happens quickly after essentially
相关性，我们不知道二者是否相连，但你说过，至少有一些证据表明睡眠可能与癌症的发展有关。确实有，而且我认为这正迅速成为强有力的因果证据。例如，我们知道，在这些精心设计的研究中，哪怕仅仅一个晚上的短睡眠——你可能在一个晚上被限制只睡四个小时。第二天，这就会使被称为自然杀伤细胞的抗癌关键细胞减少70%到70%。这是一个令人担忧的免疫缺陷状态，而且它在本质上仅仅经过
just one bad night of sleep. We also know from the associational evidence that insufficient sleep is linked to cancer of the bowel, cancer of the prostate, and cancer of the breast. And the link between a lack of sleep and cancer has since become so strong that the World Health Organization has now classified any form of nighttime shift work as a probable cast-synogen. In other words, jobs that may induce cancer
一个糟糕的夜晚后就会迅速发生。我们还从关联性证据中得知，睡眠不足与肠癌、前列腺癌和乳腺癌有关。而且缺乏睡眠与癌症之间的联系变得如此强烈，以至于世界卫生组织现在已经将任何形式的夜间轮班工作归类为可能的致癌物。换句话说，那些可能会诱发癌症的工作
because of a disruption of your sleep weight rhythms. because of a disruption of your sleep weight rhythms. Forkvina, there has been a lot of people who have been able to get a risk of breast cancer. In British Gourmet Sørens, Denmark, based on the strength of the evidence that we were just discussing, became the first country to actually pay worker compensation to women who had developed breast cancer after years of nighttime shift working, government sponsored jobs. There are clearly some professions where we do want to need people to work. Those shifts, if I have a burst appendix at three o'clock in the
因为打乱了你的睡眠觉醒节律。因为打乱了你的睡眠觉醒节律。福克维纳，有很多人因此面临乳腺癌风险。基于我们刚才讨论的证据力度，英国丹麦格雷斯索伦斯成为了第一个真正向在政府资助的工作岗位上进行多年夜间轮班工作后患上乳腺癌的女性支付工伤赔偿的国家。显然，有些职业确实需要人们去工作。那些轮班，如果我在凌晨三点阑尾爆裂，我会非常感激医院里那些照料我并救我性命的人。所以我认为自动化会有所帮助，我认为随着这场技术革命，我们可以开始在可能的情况下限制那种轮班工作。我们绝对应该这样做并开始缩减它。我认为我们还可以更好地规划职业。我们知道人们在基因上就倾向于成为夜猫子或早起鸟。所以为什么我们不问问这些问题，看看那些更喜欢我们所说的“夜猫子”（喜欢很晚睡觉、很晚起床）的人呢？为什么我们不考虑问问这些问题，看看我们是否能
morning, I'm so grateful to people at the hospital who will see to me and save my life. So I think automation is going to help, I think, with this revolution of technology, where we can start to limit that type of shift work whenever possible. We should absolutely do that and start to scale it back. We can also architect professions better, I think. We know that people are genetically predisposed to being night-time people or morning people. So why aren't we asking those questions and seeing if the people who would much prefer what we call the owls who like to sort of go to bed very late and wake up very late. Why don't we think about asking those questions and seeing if we can
帮助人们去适应我们所说的“时间型”（也就是晨型或夜型倾向），把这种倾向融入到工作灵活性和工作时间中，看看是否存在某些重叠。据我所知，在你来到伯克利之前，你曾在哈佛大学教书，当你在《哈佛克里姆森报》上写了一篇专栏文章时，你曾在教职员中引发了一些争议，你在专栏里推荐了什么？嗯，根据我们当时发表的关于睡眠对记忆有多重要的数据，我被邀请就此写一篇文章。
help people sort of fit what we call the chronotype, which is the morningness or eveningness propensity, fit that into the job flexibility in those work hours and see if there's some overlap. I understand that before you came to Berkeley, you taught at Harvard and you once served a bit of controversy among the faculty when you wrote an RPED for the Harvard Crimson, what did you recommend in the RPED? Well, I was asked based on the findings that we were publishing regarding how important sleep is for memory, to write a piece on this.
而我最终并没有去描述科学，而是直接针对教育本身的结构，因为我们在高等教育机构中倾向于设置一个学期，然后我们在那个学期或那个季度快结束时安排大量的期末考试，迫使人们把大量的信息死记硬背塞进大脑，而他们是怎么做的？他们最后都会熬夜通宵，我们做过研究，结果非常清楚。如果你熬夜通宵，你把事实硬塞进大脑的能力会变差约40%。所以这种行为是违背良好教育的。我挺身而出并表示，事实上这并不是学生的错。这是我们的错，作为教育者的错，因为我们设计了一个实际上
And I ended up rather than describing the science actually going after the structure of education itself, because what we tend to do at higher education institutes is have a long term or a semester, and then we end load that semester or that quarter with all of these finals, where people have to cram vast amounts of information to the brain, and what do they do? They end up pulling the all-nighter, and we've done the studies studies and it's very clear. If you pull the all-nighter, you're about 40% worse at cramming facts into the brain. So that behaviour is contrary to a sound education. And I went to task and I said that in fact this was not the student's fault. It was our fault, educators, because we are designing a system that actually
怂恿并鼓励这种熬夜通宵行为的体制。因此，如果我们作为教育者的目标真的是去教育学生，并且附带不在这个过程中拿生命冒险，那么我认为这种在学校学期或大学学期末尾堆砌所有这些考试的模式，让我们辜负了学生。当你还是个孩子的时候，你的家人去希腊度假，然后当你成年后再次访问希腊时，你注意到一个非常大的变化。那是什么？回到20世纪80年代我去那里度假时，商店橱窗上贴着招牌，
co-opts and encourages that type of behavior pulling the all-nighter. So if our goal as educators truly is to educate and PS not risk lives in the process, then I think we were failing our students with this model of end loading schools, school semesters or university semesters with all of these exams. When you were a kid, your family took a vacation to Greece and then when you visited Greece again as an adult, you noticed a very big change. What was it? Back in the 1980s when I went on holiday there, there were signs in the shop store windows
会标明营业时间，它们大概在10点到2点之间营业，然后上面写着下午2点到4点或2点到5点闭店休息，接着从下午5点一直营业到晚上10点或11点。这与英国本土商店的运作方式截然不同。也许有一个小时的午休或半小时的午休。大部分都是经典的9点到5点工作时间。当然，它所描述的就是这种典型的午休（Siesta）行为。现在回到20世纪90年代中期，希腊文化实际上开始放弃这种类似午休的做法。
that would give the opening hours and they would open from between sort of 10 to 2 and then it said closed between 2 to 4 or 2 to 5 pm and then open from 5 through until 10 or 11 in the evening. And it was so different to the way in which shops back in England would operate. Maybe there was a 1 hour lunch break or half hour lunch break. For the most part it was 9 to 5 hours classic. And of course what it was describing was this classic siesta-like behaviour. Now back in the mid-1990s, the Greek culture actually started to abandon the siesta-like practice.
不幸的是，或者说幸运的是，来自哈佛大学公共卫生学院的一群科学家决定量化睡眠实践中这一激进变化的健康后果。就像许多希腊悲剧一样，这里的情况也是如此，结果令人心碎，但从最字面的意义上讲，他们实际观察到的是，由于取消了午休行为，在六年期间因心脏病发作导致死亡的风险增加了37%。在工作男性中尤为明显，因心脏病发作死亡的风险几乎增加了60%。所以我认为这再次表明了睡眠是多么重要，而当睡眠被拿走时，
And unfortunately, or unfortunately, a group of scientists from Harvard University School of Public Health decided to quantify the health consequences of this radical change in sleep practice. And with many Greek tragedies, as was the case here, the results were heartbreaking, but in the most literal sense, what they actually observed was a 37% increase risk for death from heart attacks across that six-year period as a consequence of doing away with that CS2 behaviour. It was actually particularly strong in working males, almost a 60% increased risk of death from heart attacks. So I think that that again suggests not only how important sleep is and when sleep is taken
我们就会看到这种对心血管健康的危害。这实际上提出了一个不同的问题，那就是：我们应该如何睡觉？我们现代人和工业化国家的现状，是我们原本被设计的那种睡眠方式吗？答案可能真的不是，因为我们目前试图睡觉的方式被称为单相睡眠，也就是我们整晚进行单一的一段睡眠。无论我们目标如何，尽可能睡够。但如果你看看那些未受电力影响的文化，
away, we see this type of danger to our cardiovascular health. It raises actually a different question which is, how should we be sleeping? And are we sleeping currently the way in which we do through modernity and industrialized nations in the way that we were designed? The answer may actually be no, because the way that we currently try to sleep is what's called monophysics sleep, where we sleep one single about throughout the night. We aim for, however much we can. But if you look at some cultures who are untouched by electricity,
比如狩猎采集部落，他们实际上倾向于双相睡眠。他们倾向于在夜间睡上大约六、七个小时，然后下午会来个类似午休的短觉。事实证明，我们所有人都具备这种天性。这是基因硬编码的，我们所有人都有一个午餐后不久就会出现的预编程的警觉性下降。现在我们很多人认为这与我们吃的午餐有关。其实并不是。你可以不吃午餐，依然会出现这种情况。这就像是那种，你见过那些董事会
sort of hunt together a tribes, for example, they actually tend to sleep bi-phasically. They tend to sleep for sort of six, seven hours at night then they'll have a siesta-like nap in the afternoon. And it turns out that we all have this in us. It is genetically hardwired that we all have a pre-programmed drop in our alertness, some time after lunch. Now many of us think it has to do with the lunch that we have. It's actually not. You can stop the lunch and you still get it. It's this sort of, you know, you've seen those boardroom
会议吗，你知道的，在下午，你会看到很多人开始点头打瞌睡。你知道，这不是人们在听好音乐。实际上是人们向这种硬编码的、编程好的警觉性下降屈服了，这其实从进化学的角度证明了，我们应该实行双相睡眠而不是单相睡眠——应该是两段睡眠而不是一段。我必须得说，马修，在某些方面，当谈到睡眠时，人们甚至有一种吹嘘自己睡眠不足的倾向，对吧？我的意思是，当然在美国，这被视为一种荣誉的象征，你知道的，说“我睡得很少，因为我很有生产力，我工作很努力，
meetings, you know, in the afternoon, where you get lots of that head nodding that starts to happen. You know, it's not people listening to good music. It's actually people giving way to this this hardwired, programmed, drop in our alertness, which actually does argue from an evolutionary perspective that we should be sleeping by basically rather than monophasically two bouts of sleep rather than one perhaps. I have to say Matthew that in some ways when it comes to sleep there's almost a sense of people bragging about not getting enough sleep right? I mean it's certainly in the United States it's it's seen as a you know badge of honor to say you know I get very little sleep because I'm so productive and I work so hard
我取得了巨大的成就”。哦，你说得太对了，因为我们所做的事实际上是将睡眠污名化了。睡眠现在遭遇了形象危机，而且不仅在美国。我们确实会把那些获得充足睡眠的人贴上懒惰、游手好闲的标签——我非常小心地使用了这个词。这对社会是一个极大的损害。顺便说一句，我们并不总是持有这种观点。没有人会看着一个白天在睡觉的婴儿说：“多懒的婴儿啊。”我们不会，我们甚至会笑，但我们不会这么想，因为我们知道生命那个阶段的睡眠是不容商量的。它是绝对必要的。但现在，甚至在幼儿时期，我们不仅抛弃了
and I achieve so much. Oh, you're so right because what we've done is actually stigmatized sleep. Sleep has an image problem right now, and it's not just in America. And we do, we label people who get sufficient sleep, and I choose that word very carefully with being lazy, with being slothful. And that is a terrible disservice to society. And we don't always have that opinion, by the way. No one looks at an infant sleeping during the day and says, what a lazy baby. And we don't, and we laugh, but we don't because we know that sleep at that time of life is non-negotiable. It's absolutely necessary. But now, even into early childhood, not only do we abandon
睡眠很重要且应该被赞美的观念，我们还因为人们获得了充足睡眠而训斥他们，并给他们贴上这样的标签。跟我谈谈你自己的睡眠习惯，并告诉我你为了确保自己能睡个好觉都做了些什么。我听起来可能像个绝望的保守正经人，对此我非常抱歉，这听起来也很迂腐，但我确实为自己每晚提供了不容妥协的八小时睡眠机会。如果你像我一样了解这些证据，你就会相信我，不会做任何不同的事。睡眠是健康的瑞士军刀。
the notion that sleep is important and should be celebrated, we chastise people for getting sufficient sleep and give them this label. Tell me about your own sleep habits and tell me what you do to ensure you get a good night's rest. I'm going to sound like a desperate prude and I'm so sorry and it sounds hokey as well, but I actually give myself a non-negotiable eight-hour sleep opportunity every night. If you knew the evidence as I do, you would trust me, you wouldn't do anything different. Sleep is the swiss-hormy knife of health.
当睡眠不足时，就会出现疾病和生病。而当睡眠充足时，就会充满活力与健康。例如，我的家族有心血管疾病史。睡眠是夜间血压药物的一种绝妙形式。我为什么要跳过它？我为什么要向我在这个基因彩票中被赋予的基因低头，从而屈服于心血管疾病呢？所以我必须说我很抱歉，我确实身体力行我所宣扬的理念。
When sleep is deficient, there is sickness and disease. And when sleep is abundant, there is vitality and health. My family, for example, has a history of cardiovascular disease. Sleep is a wonderful form of nighttime blood pressure medication. Why would I skip on it? Why would I try to give way to the genes that I've been given in this genetic lottery and succumb to cardiovascular disease? So I have to say I'm sorry, I do practice what I preach.
你会不会努力坚持非常严格的作息时间，比如在同一时间睡觉、同一时间醒来，你用闹钟吗，你在睡前会避开科技产品吗？我会的，所以我会在某个特定时间停止查看电子邮件，我的电脑上安装了软件来消除有害的蓝光，并且我在睡前至少一个半小时就会把它们关掉。但你提到了我能给每个人的、也许是最重要的一个睡眠处方，那就是规律性。无论如何，无论是在工作日还是周末，无论是前一晚睡了个好觉还是糟糕的一晚，都在同一时间上床睡觉，在同一时间醒来，尽可能保持规律。这是最好的建议
Do you try and stick to very rigid hours when sleeping at the same time, waking up at the same time, do you use an alarm clock, do you avoid technology before you go to sleep? I do so I stop checking my email at a certain time, I have software installed on my computers that does away with the harmful blue light and I installed on my computers that does away with the harmful blue light and I shut them off at least an hour and a half before bed. But you mentioned perhaps the single most important sleep prescription that I could give everyone which is regularity. Just go to bed at the same time, wake up at the same time, no matter what, whether it's the weekday or the weekend, if you've had a good night of sleep or a bad night of sleep, stay as regular as you can. That's the best piece of advice
你会努力坚持非常严格的作息时间，比如在同一时间睡觉、同一时间醒来吗？你会用闹钟吗？你在睡前会避免使用电子产品吗？我会的，我在某个时间就会停止查看电子邮件，我的电脑上安装了能消除有害蓝光的软件，并且我在睡前至少一个半小时就会把电脑关掉。但你提到了也许我能给每个人的最重要的一条睡眠建议，那就是规律性。无论如何，无论今天是工作日还是周末，也无论你昨晚是睡了个好觉还是没睡好，都要在同一时间上床睡觉，在同一时间醒来，尽可能保持规律。这是最好的建议。
I can give you for getting good sleep at night. Matthew Walker is a professor of neuroscience in psychology at the University of California at Berkeley. He said he's sleep and he's the author of the book, Why We Sleep. Matthew, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. author of the book, Why We Sleep. Matthew, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. You're very welcome. Thank you very much and I do hope you sleep well tonight. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Path Shab. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, Renee Clark and Raina Cohen. A ronsang hero this week is Holly Hersfeld. Holly is an intern at NPR, and like many of the multi-talented interns who come to us,
我可以给你一些关于晚上睡个好觉的建议。马修·沃克是加州大学伯克利分校的神经科学与心理学教授。他说他是睡眠专家，也是《我们为什么要睡觉》一书的作者。马修，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。也是《我们为什么要睡觉》一书的作者。马修，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。不客气。非常感谢，我也希望你今晚能睡个好觉。本期《隐藏的大脑》由帕思·沙布制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔、珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼、蕾妮·克拉克和雷娜·科恩。本周的幕后英雄是霍莉·赫尔斯菲尔德。霍莉是NPR的一名实习生，就像许多来到我们这里的多才多艺的实习生一样，
Holly happens to have a special skill. She plays the piano. When we wanted someone to play a piano riff for us at the start of this episode, we turned to her. Thanks so much Holly. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram, and listen for my stories on your local public radio station.
霍莉刚好有一项特殊技能。她会弹钢琴。当我们想在本集开头找人弹一段钢琴爵士乐时，我们找到了她。非常感谢霍莉。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并收听你在当地公共广播电台播出的我的故事。
If you haven't subscribed to the podcast, please do. And if you've never told a friend about Hidden Brain, try it, and see how much more they love you. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. I hope you have sweet dreams tonight. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你还没有订阅这个播客，请订阅。如果你从未向朋友推荐过《隐藏的大脑》，不妨试试，看看他们会有多爱你。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。祝你今晚做个好梦。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。